Just like titles in a bookshop are divided
into fiction and non-fiction, we can communicate
along a spectrum ranging from colorful storytelling
to stating plain facts.
When fiction and nonfiction speak to us, they
serve opposing purposes.
To understand this difference, let's examine
the definition, and then a famous example
of a classic tragedy.
The Tragedy is a type of dramatic work in
which the main character experiences a downfall
due to circumstances that are beyond their
control.
Traditionally, the intention of tragedy is
to invoke an accompanying catharsis - a "pain
that awakens pleasure".
Now the fiction!
Once upon a time a boy was born to the king
and queen of Thebes.
The boy's name was Oedipus.
Soon after his birth, a prophet warned the
king that the boy would grow up to kill his
father and marry his mother.
To avoid this catastrophe, the king ordered
one of his servants to kill the baby.
But the servant couldn’t do it and left
the innocent child with a shepherd.
The shepherd brought the boy to the king of
Corinth, who raised him as his own.
When Oedipus grew to be a man, a prophet told
him his destiny.
Not knowing that he had been adopted, Oedipus
left Corinth to run away from his misfortune.
On his way to Thebes, he met an old man with
his servants.
The two got into a fight and Oedipus killed
them all.
When Oedipus arrived in Thebes, he encountered
the evil Sphinx that menaced the city.
After Oedipus solved the Sphinx's riddle,
it killed itself.
To celebrate this victory, Oedipus was named
the new king of Thebes, and given the current
queen as his bride - for the former king had
mysteriously been killed.
Years later, after they had four children,
plagues began to destroy the city.
Oedipus tried to find out the reason for this
misfortune when he heard rumors that Thebes
would be doomed until the day that the murderer
of the former king was punished.
Oedipus first tried to find the villain, and
then began to understand what had actually
happened.
When he realized that he had killed his father
and made love to his mother, he blinded himself,
as he could not bear to see the children he
had fathered.
Now what do you think about the two examples?
And how do the two help you understand a tragedy?
The story appears real and feels alive.
You can experience it, sense it emotionally,
see it with your imagination.
And because this can be exciting, it is recorded
in your brain, changes your mind, and will
be remembered for a long time.
But there is a downside.
Stories are so powerful, you may start to
think they are more common than they are,
and you become biased.
This effect is also known as "the law of small
numbers".
Which is why we also need facts.
Facts are abstract, and boring.
Reading nonfiction is not exciting, and is
hence not easily recorded in your memory.
In fact, a mere month after reading an entire
book, most of us remember not more than one
single idea.
And because facts are weak and they compete
for attention with stories that are powerful,
they hardly ever change your mind.
However, there is one thing they do well.
Nonfiction provides our mind a theory, a heuristic,
and a framework that allows us to make assumptions,
and generalize.
Put them on a spectrum and you’ll find:
High retention vs low retention
Easy reading vs hard studying
And a subjective perspective vs objectivity.
For their polarizing nature, smart educators
often combine the two.
Just as the quote goes: When one man dies,
it's a tragedy, and when a million die, it’s
statistics.
To better understand the true nature of war,
we need to consider both.
What do you think?
What will you learn from this video?
Possibly a good mix of both worlds?
Share your thoughts and your favorite way
to grasp complex topics in the comments below!
If you like how we explain complicated ideas
in simple cartoon animation, you can support
us.
Visit patreon.com/sprouts.
Just visit us, learn how it works, and what’s
in it for you.
We hope to see you there!
And if you are a parent or an educator, check
our website sproutsschools.com There you’ll
find this and other video lessons, additional
resources, and classroom activities.
If you found this helpful, check out our other
videos and subscribe!
If you want to support our work, join us on
patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional contents,
visit sproutsschools.com.